outside the meeting room if the fire
alarm should sound please please leave
the meeting room by following the fire
exit signs do not re-enter the building
until you are told it is safe to do so
please switch off all mobile phones or
turn them to
silent I'd like to remind everyone
present that this meeting will be
broadcast live to the internet and will
be capable of repeated viewing the whole
of the meeting will be filmed except
where there are confidential or exempt
items if you make a representation to
the meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed by entering this meeting you are
also consenting to being filmed by the
council and to the possible use of those
images and sound recordings for
webcasting and or training purposes the
council members of the public and the
Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully
excluded can I remind members to speak
clearly into the the microphones and to
not put their papers over the
microphones can I move to the agenda
please apologies for
absence thank you chair we have received
apologies from councelor Austin Davis
councelor linia Hingham councelor David
David Napier councelor Matthew Hicks
councelor Nikki Wilshire and councelor
Miles
row thank you um Declarations of
Interest by Council
I'd just like to say that the monitor
officer has granted dispensations to all
councils regarding the joint local plan
are there any other Declarations of
Interest
no um item three MC
2325 to confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on 26th of October 2020 3
for accuracy only are there any issues
with
accuracy could I have a proposal
please uh councelor eurn could I have a
second look please councelor
Carter all those in favor could I just
have a show of hands
please that is
carried uh item four MC
2326 chair
announcements uh I refer you to paper MC
2326 for
noting thank
you item
five I'd like to invite Council melon to
present his
update thank you chair um just three
short uh updates on this occasion um
firstly cozy Holmes last week the
council was able to launch the mids
suffk cozy homes scheme this2 million
pound investment will make hundreds of
homes in our district more energy
efficient lowering their energy bills
and reducing their carbon emissions in
the process this work will be carried
out free of charge for those people who
are eligible and this is funding for the
likes of Loft insulation cavity wall
insulation and draft proofing works it
is aimed at private homeowners in our
district who meet the criteria and
landlords with less than five properties
so we want to improve the EPC rating of
hundreds of homes for more details about
the criteria and how to apply I would
encourage people to visit our website I
would also encourage members to spread
the word to your communities about this
excellent scheme and I acknowledge that
this is funded by cross party agreement
on last year's
budget secondly financial report for
those impacted by flooding it's a month
since severe flooding hit a number of
our communities and for many of our
residents the process of recovery
continues can I pay tribute to members
who got stuck in to help their
communities during the immediate crisis
and
sins the government has announced grants
for homes and businesses that were
impacted so it's £500 for homes and
25,000 for businesses uh to assist with
the initial recovery costs now mids
District Council has been working with
neighboring districts and suffer County
Council to get these grants to those
eligible as quickly as we can we will be
able to start Distributing flooding
before the end of this month but I would
like to remind everyone that all reports
of property flooding need to be
submitted via the suffk County Council
website we will be reviewing our
response to the flooding to see what
could be improved and also how we can
build more resilience into our
communities and thirdly and finally
Gateway 14 tomorrow I and other members
will be attending the official official
unveiling of the new building at Gateway
14 to be occupied by garden and Leisure
products retailer the
range completion of this building is a
significant milestone for Gateway 14 and
mids suffer by bringing its operations
to Stow Market the range is creating
hundreds of new jobs for the region and
providing a boost for the local economy
they also the first business to come to
Gateway 14 uh with the site taking shape
as a major landmark for business in
innovation in the East we hope that more
business will soon join and I'm really
pleased that this building has been
constructed with high environmental
standards as we want this whole
development to be an Exemplar of good
sustainable practice thank you
chair thank you councilor Mel uh are
there any points for clarification
please councelor
Elin thank you chair um I just wanted to
um ask acknowledging that officers in in
um mids and the County Council been
working very hard to identify everybody
who's been impacted by the flooding but
anecdotally we know that there are still
people who perhaps aren't aware of the
support that's available especially
people who aren't uh very active online
so I just wanted to ask if there was
anything more we could do as counselors
and as a council to make sure that we
reach everyone and and don't leave
anyone behind thank
you Council
M yeah I think um this is the the point
at which award counselor has a really
important role to try and pick up on
these things and make sure that everyone
um in their parishes is aware of the of
the help that's available um you know
through your Parish councils through
your through your Parish Clarks and your
networks in in the community as well um
I think it's um there's potential for
some confusion here about um who's
responsible and where the money is
coming from uh and we certainly don't
want to have any kind of
um a lack of or a gap of information
between the county and the district I
don't know if Arthur you've got anything
to add to that in terms of who's
responsible and and how people make make
sure they get that
money yes thank you chairman and and to
the leader so the County Council is the
lead local flood Authority but really
that's a technicality I think when it
comes to these things in reality it's
the district council and the County
Council working hand in glove because
the County Council are the ones that are
holding the funding the link into
government they are doing the data
collection but in terms of contacting
residents that's something that we're
doing through our customer services team
so the information is being passed
through from the county so those that
have logged on as the leader described
um we will be contacting those customers
those residents starting this week um
directly contact to them short form for
them to fill in you can do that online
and that's that's basically collecting
payment details so that we can make sure
that those payment details go out um
exactly the same principle with
businesses as well but slightly more
complicated just because at the moment
there's a disconnect between the way in
which the two schemes that government
have designed they don't quite talk to
each other but the same principle so
we're expecting to be contacting
residents sorry contacting businesses
from the following week um so hopefully
the two authorities um in terms of mid
of the County Council working hand in
glub on this anything that clearly
anything that Ward councilors can do if
you do come across residents who have
been affected haven't previously met us
let us know either come direct into the
district council and we can help them do
that even better go straight into the
County Council and register their
addresses any further points of
clarification Council
Penny yeah I just wanted to flag up that
the the actual number reported in the
Press is not a reflection of the true
number there are some some households
who are reluctant to register as as they
are of the opinion that it will affect
their house insurance going going
forwards I just really wanted to raise
raise that point I don't know if the
council has noticed this
elsewhere yeah anecdotally I've heard
the same thing that people are looking
not to claim on their house insurance
because they don't want you know the um
the kind of repercussions of a Big Bill
in the future or you know unable to um
sell the house uh I still would I think
encourage people to apply for the for
the the funding that's what it's there
for I mean anyone buying a house is
going to look look and and probably find
out that a house has been flooded um
some other way even if they don't find
it through um declaration that a
householder might make um so I think
there's potential for a bit of a kind of
um a Mis Place concern there the money
is there it's supposed to help it will
help but only if people apply for
it any further
points
um can I move on to item six then uh
notification of petitions in accordance
with Council procedure rules F
received item seven questions by the
public in accordance with Council
procedure rules nonone received
chair questions by councilors in
accordance with Council procedure
rules n received
chair I'm now moving to item nine MC
2327 the babber and miter joint local
development scheme 23-
26 I'd like to invite Council Stringer
to introduce paper MC
2327 and to move the recommendation in
the report uh for your information we've
got Tom D Barker the director of
Planning and Building control president
and Robert Hobs the corporate manager
for strategic planning
um I have been warn Council Stringer May
slightly exceed his a lot of five
minutes if so then I will allow
uh other responses the same amount of
time thank thank you chairman I'll try
and stay in time with this paper I might
transgress on the next one who knows um
yes mids it's a pleasure to be able to
introduce the bab and mids joint local
development scheme 2023 to
2026 um it's not long ago we we actually
had had another one but we we we've got
a sort of interesting timetable that we
need to try and keep to here uh and
introduce some new uh supplementary
planning documents so the baby and M
joint local development scheme is the
local planning authorities work program
for the preparation of development plan
documents following completion of the
examination of Baba and midu Joint local
plan a review of the local development
scheme LDS is necessary to bring up to
date the current timetable for the
preparation of the joint local plan part
one and part two development plan
documents it's also necessary to review
the LDS to be able to cope and and able
to adopt joint local plan part
one which we hope to a little bit later
today the LDS also revises the timetable
for the preparation of the revised
Community infrastructure Levy seal
charging schedule for the district and
nine supplementary planning documents
spds an additional SPD is introduced on
air quality to provide further guidance
and detail for assessing air quality
impacts on sensitive environmental
receptors this LDS would replace the
current one adopted in October 2022 and
adopting this LDS would enable the
council to provide Clarity on current
anticipated time scales for the
preparation of planning documents and is
necessary to be able to adopt joint
local plan part
one please can we note that what we're
voting on in terms of the timetable
tonight is the one identified in
appendix a and not the one that's in the
background document uh that's the one
that was approved uh last year just for
that for Clarity uh and and where
whereas others will probably uh you'll
be about to get some of these suppl
planning documents sent to you uh for
comment and for for us to be working
them up uh which will be uh good uh and
now I've
clarified where what timetable we're
voting on I'd like to propose the
recommendation under 3.1 on page 22 Jim
and I look for a
second
thank you very much chair I'm happy to
second that I think this is a really
important document to go with this um
the the other document today it's really
good to have a schedule laid out like it
is we can all follow that we can keep
that going and I'm looking forward to
the spds coming out and um getting to
grips with those thank you very much
thank you Council
custom um we'll now move to questions
Council may ask as many questions as
they wish however they must be relevant
to the subject under discussion and must
be a
question Council
Watters that's all right um I think this
process started in 2016 and is due to
end in
2026 that's a decade is that normal that
the process takes this
long yeah uh thank you councelor winch
um in in my experience of uh planning
policy uh a decade can slip by in a very
very short amount of time uh I I think
there's been two substantial documents
planning documents policy documents I
voted on since I've been here 20 in 20
years oh no I didn't vote on The Joint
local plan uh the first local plan in 98
it was already here so I had one
substantial document which was the core
strategy document in 20 years so yes it
is frustrating that the time scale seem
to be very very long but of course we do
have to fit an inspector's timetable and
we do have to be incredibly open and
transparent about what we're doing and
we have to allow the public and the
developers to object have all their
objections looked at cved through by an
inspector and most of this has to be
timetable to be done in public which is
and quite rightly so and that all does
delay the process I hope that
helps
counc Council
Manson thank you chair um I'd just like
to ask if there is any um timetable or
um plan for review of part one uh or
does that come after
2026 um I might have to rely on officers
about some of the detail but yes there
will be a review uh there will probably
have to be a review within five years of
adoption yeah within five years of
adoption um and and frankly I'd like to
see us use some of the spds to hone try
out honing those policies because an SPD
is a is an Ask rather than a requirement
of a developer so that we might then
have tried some of these ideas out uh
and these policies so that they can be
then introduced into uh The Joint local
plan at a possible review
have we got any further
questions as the questions are finished
we will now now move to the debate
councilors will be only be allowed to
speak once for three minutes and this
will be
timed do I have anyone
to debate matter Council
Manel is nobody else going to going to
say anything about this this important
document um now I mean I think it's
fantastic that we have actually now got
to the stage of of having our joint
local plan orbe it part one uh has been
a long process as has already been
pointed out in the questioning um we
currently have a
1998 um local plan and we are constantly
told that it's not up to date um so
although this may not be perfect it is
certainly more up to date than the
existing 1998 local plan which is what
we have to rely on at the moment so I I
welcome this new plan I think it has got
some interesting um wording and some new
policies that will hopefully add a bit
of certainty to the planning decision-
making process uh and I also welcome the
fact that it's going to be reviewed uh
within five years um and the fact that
we've got this extensive number of spds
uh to look forward to which will
hopefully help to clarify um the
policies that are in our our local plan
um and I think that we should all be
well I I certainly will be um voting for
the um the the program the timeline um
showing that what we're going to do um
in order to get this uh these spds um
off the ground so um I think it's been a
long process and and we're now actually
going to see um some fruition thank
you thank you Council Council
reurn thank you very much chair um and
thank you to to colleagues to um members
and to officers for all the work they've
done on on this um the local development
scheme the timetable I just think it's
really important to have that um I was
going to say in black and white it's in
black yellow red blue all the different
so um with regards to really clearly
laying out the timetable for um both
obviously hopefully will'll actually
agree The Joint local plan part one in
in the next item but that the the
timetable for the part two but more
importantly or not more importantly but
additionally all of the spds because I
think those are things that that we as
as members can really affect and we can
really get um the kind of um buy in or
um understanding from our communities as
to which which elements are important to
them and get the comments on board Bo to
make those the best they can be and then
when we do get to review um the the
overall plan we've actually got a really
good idea of what what is needed in our
district so I think it's really
important that we've got a very clear
timetable which we have before us here
um and I just want to ensure that we
have the right resource behind it to
ensure that we can get those spds
through and that the this Tim table
doesn't slip and if we if we feel that
there's an issue there that we you know
highlight that immediately because we it
has been a really long time in coming
and we've really must ensure we kind of
keep up a pace as it were to get those
spds um through to the time table we've
got in front of us today but I will
definitely be supporting this item today
thank you
chair thank you
counil would anyone else like to
speak Council M thank you chair yeah
well I too would very much welcome this
this document um unfortunately I I can
remember a few years ago um stumbling
across one of the forerunners of of this
um this document today also called the
local development scheme and um it was I
realized it was 18 months out of date uh
so that'll give you some idea about the
sort of time scales and things that
we're actually actually dealing with so
it's just so welcome to get all these um
all these what was it 32 policies was it
Andrew um actually tabulated into into a
a single place where we can refer to
them instead of the sort of previous rag
bag of of assorted saved policies as the
Jaren has it and um so that's absolutely
great and I look forward to um using it
next Wednesday I think it is thank
you
thank you Council
Walters thanks chair um yeah so um
likewise I'd like to um show my
appreciation to the offices to councelor
Stringer um and Echo comments already
made um as a newcomer to the chamber um
with the green background that I have um
it's lovely to see these spds on
biodiversity well-being health um air
quality uh and and the like um and it's
and it's great to see it laid out in
such a um an organized fashion so that
we can give each of these extremely
important subjects du course and
attention um and uh yes I shall
certainly be supporting this
project thank you
councelor any further points anyone
would like to to
make thank you as um councelor Stringer
would you like to finish would you like
to add anything um be very brief um
thank you to counselors uh for the
questions and the observations just to
just clarify because some of the debate
to drift into this document we are we
are just creating the timetable with
this vote to allow this document to be
looked at and to formally bring about uh
us being able to communicate with you
about these spds uh and and I certainly
hope that the drafts of these and the
discussion of those happens fairly
fairly early I think I was aiming rather
than to give you all Christmas cards
this year I was going to be giving you
sort of an SPD every day for about a
fortnite for you to chew over where you
know other people might have the 12 Days
of Christmas you'll have the 10 spds of
your tide that's what we're hoping for
uh because a lot of these policies will
seriously affect what what is built how
it is built and more importantly the
impact it will have in terms of
addressing uh stuff like biodiversity uh
net gain and also the affordability of
houses and also the sustainability of
houses so uh I'm going to say no more
about it just encourage everyone to vote
for this joint local development scheme
thank you chair thank
you I'll will now ask the assistant
manager governance to conduct the
electronic
vote thank you chair um Council that
vote is now on the agenda item is now
showing in Blue on your modern. goov
app councelor Willer can I help you I've
got um a fatal it error but I can cast
my vote verbally which is in favor thank
you councelor
Pearson
four thank
you thank you chair that is 28 votes for
that's
carried that is carried I'd I like to
move to item 10 MC
2328 babber adits a joint local plan for
adoption I'd like to invite Council
Stringer to introduce paper MC 2328 and
to move the recommendation in the
report thank you chair uh apologies it's
me again uh this is a actually quite a
big deal this document it's been an
awful long time in the coming there's
been an awful lot of meetings and
discussions and arguing and all of of
that to get this to this stage um in
fact I was having a discussion with uh
just to show you the time scales of
planning documents I was having a
discussion uh with councelor maton uh at
the weekend and he was saying he was
going through some uh paperwork and he'd
come across a an anniversary uh last
Friday was the 30th anniversary of the
closure of consultations on the 1998
joint uh 1998 local plan uh and and and
a certain Mr Matson had got an objection
in there from mids Friends of the earth
uh suggesting that the developments we
were proposing were not sustainable
enough that we didn't have enough water
etc etc all of the things that are
grappled with in this document here so I
hope now Council maton won't be
objecting to this plan in in the way he
had reservations about the 1998 plan uh
and and I think there's much in this
plan to commend it
um on the 19th of September 2023 the
planning inspectors undertaking the
examination on the babber and minu Joint
local plan concluded in their report
that part one development plan document
can be made sound and capable of
adoption subject to a number of main
modifications this brought to a close an
examination that commenced following
submission of the bab and mids joint
local plan to the then Secretary of
State for housing communities and local
government on the 31st of March 21 for
those of you counting that's five
Secretary of States and three prime
ministers ago work on the joint local
plan commenced in the summer of
2016 and the plan has been through three
different iterations an extensive
consultation before examination
commencing in
2021 I would personally like to thank
the officers who have produced and
progressed the plan to this point
special mention to our planning policy
team Rob and rest thank you very much
who've spent many days mon month and
years ensuring that a sound plan could
be produced and who have navigated the
examination process diligently I would
also at this point like to thank
previous portfolio holders David burn
and clyve arthy from babber for their
diligence in getting this plan to where
it is today the adoption of the plan is
a significant
Milestone uh that enables the district
to agree an upto-date planning framework
to guide sustainable development and
facilit take growth to
2037 it provides a set of strategic and
local development management policies
which will be used to inform decisions
on planning applications and appeals the
plan has also been informed by an
extensive evidence base and has been
subject to sustainability appraisal
incorporating strategic environmental
assessment and to Habitat habitats
regulations assessment The Joint local
plan part one with the modifications
Incorporated is appended in appendix a
the main modifications are summarized in
the council report and detailed in the
inspector's report at appendix B
adopting The Joint local plan part one
ensures the council councils have an
upto-date local plan document that
enables the focused joint local plan
part two development plan document to
progress as detailed in the local
development scheme recently approved
agree this will allow us to reassert a
plan-based approach to our future
development I encourage all of you I
mean I personally know what it feels
like to have an out ofd plan U and and
to being going into Chambers uh without
sufficient policy I would urge every
counselor to vote for this so we can get
back to that plan-based approach thank
you
chair thank you councilor Stringer do I
have a second Council
Casten thank you chair yeah I completely
age agree with everything councilor
string has said there this is an
incredibly important document I fully
support it it's a coordinated and
cohesive Str strategy for development it
involves a huge amount of collaboration
and consultation that's gone on and a Hu
it represents a massive amount of work
it's um it's absolutely essential so
that we can make sure that the future
growth in mids suffk is planned and
consistent and sustainable and um it's
also matched well with the
infrastructure and services that we have
so um yeah thank you very much for
letting me second
it thank you counselor have any
questions
counc thank you chair I would um also
just like to add um my thanks uh to the
uh Cabinet member for planning and uh
and the officers who have um and and War
members of course who have worked really
really hard um on this document over the
years um just a quick question sorry um
so Wildlife trusts have advocated for
local policies that achieve biodiversity
net gain at a target of
20% um and that is that developments
would leave biodiversity in a 20% uh
measurably better State uh than before
um whilst the cabinet cabinet member
planning pushed hard for that 20%
Target um could he please explain uh for
the purpose of clarification why we were
only able to include a target of 10% in
our policy uh document and are there
other means to achieve the best outcome
for nature recovery in the district
within that
framework well I thank councelor Pratt
for the for the question um yes we we
did argue uh at at the appeal inspection
stage that perhaps mids could have a
target of greater than 10% biodiversity
net gain and the argument was put to the
inspector uh but sadly in this case the
inspector didn't agree so they've agreed
that every single development will have
to lift up their biodiversity net gain
by 10% but for me that that's not oh
well we've only got 10% and walk away
absolutely not uh we've got
supplementary planning documents coming
forward um and and actually I think any
ecologist would agree I'm not one myself
but I think any ecologist would agree
just having a blanket Target for
biodiversity Net game for all
development is actually slightly
shortsighted and it actually doesn't fit
the ground and turf we're on for some
developments if you've got a very
species Rich site that has protected
species on it 10% gain could be a
challenge if you've got a arable field
and you're putting solar farm on it with
wild flowers growing underneath
100% wouldn't be a huge challenge you
could get more than 100% And and I think
what a blanket percentage doesn't
identify is that almost every site is
different so I'm looking to us as a
council and you counselors to engage in
our SPD process so that we get a
cracking set of supplementary planning
documents that do get the very most
biodiversity net gain we can from every
single site that this Council approves
so that on average we do a lot better
than 10% across the board
recognizing that if we'd have perhaps
pushed for even further on 20% or even
30% we may then get appealed and knocked
back by developers that would find that
difficult because they have a species
Rich site so I think what we've got is a
framework that doesn't necessarily fit
all tasks and what I'm asking is let's
try and get a policy with the spds that
does help us to deliver a greater
percentage overall hope that answers the
question thank you thank you counil
Stringer
there any
further Council wi um I think a lot of
residents looking through this would
find the detail quite complex and
certainly there's a newcomer coming in I
found that myself if you were speaking
to a typical resident and you had 60
seconds to explain to them what the
benefit was what would you be
saying I'd be saying this is a planning
document can I have more than 60 seconds
that would be the first thing I'd say
what what I what I would say is I'm I
mean I I don't want to get down on the
1998 local plan that was a very very
good document it saw mids suffk quite
well for a number of years it well out
past it sell by date frankly but it was
still plugging away and doing some good
work um I hope this document you does as
much good and lasts as long if I wanted
to boil it down I think where this where
this document will deliver is insisting
on a lot of those things that we expect
from development it isn't it isn't by
any stretch of the imagination perfect I
don't think any planning document ever
is they also should be an itera document
that gets changed over time but I
certainly think to uh what I would say
in 60 seconds Ting I've already gone
over that uh that I would say to your
residents in layman's terms that if this
is approved and I hope it will very
shortly this will help us deliver more
of those aspirations of those
communities be It Better Built
environment better outcomes better
design better environmental impact and
and better sustainability for our
communities so that's probably what I P
attention thank you for the
question Council over
it thank you chair um noting the
positive encouragement for new homes for
our community land trusts is it possible
for new homes built on CLT land to have
any protections from right to buy
legislation good good question it's
probably a question for another
portfolio holder but I'll answer it
anyway um Community Land trusts do have
protection under under the right to buy
legislation at the moment that could
well change so actually encouraging
Community Land Trust to bring forward uh
social housing is a very very good thing
because those houses at the moment will
not be subject to the right to buy there
also are a number of registered
providers that also have exemption from
right to buy policies because they're
self-funding they're very low in number
I won't name them but that they do exist
whereas if the council or normal
registered social landlords bring
forward affordable housing or social
housing we are subject to that same
right to buy so yes you're correct clts
are at Community Land Trust are at there
at this Administration would like to
encourage those uh to to to be a major
hopefully a major part of our
development going forward so it really
democratized that social housing I think
that's a brilliant aim to have and I
thank you for the
question thank you do you have any
further
questions
um as the questions finished uh we will
now move to the debate councils will
only be allowed to speak once for three
minutes and this will be
timed Council scaf
thank you chair yeah I was very
interested in the response to the 10%
net biodiversity gain uh question
because I think actually the council
could set and lead by example in
development of its schemes whether it's
housing or whatever it's developing and
actually show the way to develops how
you can incorporate a more than 10% net
biodiversity gain on our own scheme so I
think that's something the council I
hope will will consider on any schemes
that they bring forward in the next four
years because I think we should leave by
example
that's the only way to encourage
developers to do exactly the same if you
if you provide an Exemplar site others
will look to you and go oh well that's
an interesting site I I think we can
match that so I think by Leading by
example we could we could show the
way have we got
any
sry oh Council
Millan yeah thank you chair um
just to highlight the importance of
getting this plan through I just want to
relate my experience as a ward counselor
um for the last four years in bton when
I was first elected back in
2019 uh The Joint local plan was already
something that officers and and
councelors had been working on for a
considerable time and later I think it
was that same year we were all presented
with a a large document the draft JP
which I still have somewhere on a Shelf
at home I think I had to reinforce the
Shelf pretty heavy so when this document
came out it really felt like we were
making progress towards a plan based
system for planning unfortunately at
that time the council did not have a
housing land supply of more than 5 years
so it was very difficult to uh to refuse
or for the council to refuse speculative
planning
applications so I found myself as a new
and inexperienced counselor having to
come along to planning committees and
represent my community and speak against
some large
developments unfortunately I wasn't
particularly persuasive and and we
didn't have the five-year land Supply so
these sites which were actually outside
the proposed settlement boundary for
bton did get approval so in total with
with a site approved before I was a
counselor there's three major sites in
bton my biggest village that were
approved and now being bu built out but
in each case there were kind of
significant
concerns about each site but the lack of
an upto-date local plan meant that they
got approved so I have been looking
forward to the level of certainty about
planning that having a local plan
brings having also sat on a planning
committee for about three years I think
this plan will make committee members
lives easier a little bit and hopefully
planning officers work a little bit
easier in the future
so often uh when someone comes to you a
member of the public or a resident with
a question about planning the answer has
been well it depends I think we can move
on from that a little bit when we get
this plan approved and be able to give
them a little bit more certainty I
certainly want to add my uh tribute to
the the staff and the counselors who've
been working on this for so long and I'm
going to vote for it today thank
you thank thank you I was just going to
say something about the um net gain the
10% yeah it is um it does seem like a
small amount of Net game but this needs
to be something that we that works that
doesn't get turned over and appeal and
we do have an SPD document coming in
which is fantastic you know we can we
can work on that quite often we need to
look at different species we can't 10 a
10% net gain on every um development for
the same five species is not what we
want either I think if we can focus on
that area and what's What's um what we
need to provide for in that area that
would be a fantastic SPD but yeah
totally totally agree um 10% as a
minimum is um you know it it doesn't
seem a lot but that SPD will make a big
difference the um I think this document
is what we as we discussed before in the
work working party this is um what we
need the SPD is what we can ask for and
the more realistic the ask for what we
when we ask for what we need for the
more likely we can get to the um what we
want thank
you Council Brad
bre thank you um I'd actually like to
return to one of the developments which
um Andy melon mentioned um in bton that
one of the large developments there was
granted permission on the condition that
the development would be generating so
much um solar energy um looking at the
number of the houses there the solar
panels are put on the north side of the
house um so thus generating nothing um
which would in my opinion not as an
expert but would appear to be in a
breach of planning will if this
development uh plan is adopted will the
council be putting additional funds into
planning enforcement um just to make
sure that we at least hit that 10% thank
you thank
you counc
re thank you chair um to say I'm really
pleased that this um joint local plan is
is coming forward um part one we've
still got part two to come which is
another long time table but um we'll
we'll tackle that one um and I think
just with um regards to you know I was
found this kind of quite a complicated
um subject to discuss with with
residents with Paris councils um and you
know you see people's eyes glaze over
sorry to the um planning policy officers
concerned but people do so you know when
you start talking about policy and just
really understanding it and I think one
of the um the points that I would say
that it's kind of a set of um strategic
and local development management
policies of against which you know we're
um determining planning applications and
also appeals will be assessed but within
it there's 10 strategic policies so that
areas such as affordable housing climate
change and tourism and I think that that
makes sense to communities when you when
you state that but there's also 32 local
policies so on things such as historic
environment um sustainable construction
and town centers so again when you
actually come down to the individual
policy it's something that everybody can
can understand and can relate to their
own Community or their own locality and
as such it's a really good um you know
planning framework um for the whole
District but again it can be localized
too so I think it's um it's great that
this has come forward and um I look
forward to um it being approved
hopefully this evening and um then
seeing what happens with part two thank
you
chair Council
Manson thank you chair um I I too
welcome this uh this new document uh and
I hope uh all the members of the
planning committee are also welcoming it
uh because it it it hopefully it's it's
written clearly um um and we can
understand the policies um and hopefully
our planning officers will help to guide
us to making decisions using this new
local plan um but of course the proof
will be um in any appeal um when that uh
goes um do do our new policies stand up
um uh to an appeal um hopefully they
will do uh and I too was also going to
say that this is only half the story we
do still need our our part two um this
does provide a basis uh on which to to
start making planning decisions um but
uh I think part two is is another uh
tricky process um this has been through
a long process um and it's gone through
several iterations and we have what what
we're going to hopefully approve today
which will then become policy I think
from the minute we approve it um it
becomes policy um so yes I uh I think
there there are a lot of a lot of
policies here which will will make sense
to our communities and it's certainly a
big Improvement on our 1998 local plan
which is what we're using currently this
this plan has been made um to comply
with the mppf um we we currently have
our land Supply we need to just make
sure we keep hold of our land Supply um
so that going forwards we can rely on
these policies along with part two um
which is yet to be developed I I think
that will be a difficult process and I
hope that we're all get involved in in
um the production of part two but I will
be supporting this motion thank
you thank you Council
any
further points people would like to make
councilor
Stringer thank you chair uh just to sort
of wrap up I'll answer the question
about enforcement if I can uh and just
to say that with a crisper set of
policies that slightly clearer a and and
a more direct approach in certain areas
the same resource we already have
enforcement should actually be able to
do those other areas I believe you uh
that you were you were alluding to so uh
so anyway but if there are any
enforcement issues that you feel aren't
getting the results they should please
please let me know and we will discuss
it with the team talking to the team
thank you very much to the team that
we've finally got a document that is
crisp ready to go uh with the chair's
indulg I didn't ask you to come in on
any of the questions are there any
points you'd like to make uh when I
finish is that okay CH if I ask them um
if the team would like to make any
points that would be uh really helpful
and I just want to finish up by uh
saying um this is now a chance where we
can actually look forward and not look
over our shoulder which I feel we've
been doing for a number of years
worrying about what government policy is
because we've got to you know wholly you
know be in line with that and and that
our policies out of date therefore we
must do this and must do that uh but in
approving this this doesn't end the work
it actually starts it because we've got
all those sbds to sort out we've got
part two to sort out which will be you
know a huge Clash of aspirations and
developers wanting X and communities
wanting y but I think this gives us a
good starting position to have that that
discussion um I also would make the plea
to those settlements that have got or
are thinking about getting NE
neighorhood plans don't think that
approving this then means your
neighborhood plan you needn't worry
about updating it or keeping it fresh or
carrying on please do please do uh
neighborhood plans as far as this
Administration is concerned are a vital
part of that conversation about what
you'd like to see in your communities
and how you'd like it to be developed
and heaven forbid if we ever were to
have this plan being ruled as being out
of date an up to- dat neighborhood plan
and the current government policy would
would still be be a good thing to have
uh so with with with that uh all all of
that clarified I just like to say thank
you to everyone again thank you to all
the questions and thank you for the
support from uh those across the other
side Ro of course you were a major part
of seeing this document as as far as
it's got today uh I will C and I'll move
approval on the recommendation and and
and hope everyone else will vote for it
thank you
chair thank you
I will now ask the assistant manager
governance to
conduct
off officers was going to say something
oh sorry um officer officer thank thank
you chair um yeah just thank you to
counselors as well um and as you say
it's been going since 2016 so there's
been a lot of counselors input in this
um thank you to the communities um
everyone who's had an interest in the
process we've gone through three um
extensive consultations it's been a two
and a half year examination with number
of hearings so it's been um a very
involved process but yeah I mean so big
thank you to the officers in the
planning policy team who've lived this
every day and produced a plan and also
officers across the whole um councils
who have input as well from different
departments different teams into this
process um and uh yeah just reiterate
the point um it's really important that
we have an upto-date plan in place um
and um
make sure that um yeah we progress with
part two as quickly as we can make sure
it's Rob
us thank you officer
OBS I would now ask the assistant
manager for governance to conduct the
electronic
vote thank you chair uh that vote is now
showing in Blue on your app you might
have to scroll down a bit to to find the
blue
line
councel Pearson may I take your vote
please four thank
you councelor
Willer
councelor Marriot are sorry I can't get
the may I take your vote please four
thank
you that's 28 votes for thank you
um I I before I announce the results to
the vote I think this is a momentous
moment for the council it's a
culmination of not just hours of work
but years of work continuous engagement
by the officers uh with communities I
think it's a tremendous job well done
that's
[Applause]
carried
uh item 11 Council appointments are
there any changes to
placings
none uh item 12 motions on
notice none received
chair right as our next meeting is on
Thursday the 25th of January
2024 at 5:30 I'd just like to take this
opportunity as the lights are already
going up over suffk and the shops are
filling up with Min pies I'd like to
take the opportunity to hope for a pie a
peaceful and Co of Christmas for you for
all our officers and all our residents
uh the meeting is closed thank
you and